on a atteint 7 et -9 degrés par endroits
météo france annonce que c'est la nuit
d'avril la plus froide depuis depuis
depuis 75 ans exactement alors
heureusement la consommation électrique
est légèrement plus faible que les
prévisions ce qui a permis au réseau de
transport électrique de l'assuré
entièrement et pourtant 27 réacteurs
nucléaires sur 56 sont indisponibles
pour maintenance ou vérification de
problèmes de corrosion et on s'étonne
trente ans après on vous mais nous on a
tort c'est la remise et la corrosion
s'étonne oui oui vous êtes gentils la
corrosion il ya la moindre fissure en
français oui bon on arrête tout le label
formidable et vous avez des gens pour
vous expliquer que le nucléaire c'est
pas sûr mais
mettons collinaires des antilles et je
cuisine la cuisine antillaise les acras
de morue je pars très bon va souvent
traité de me re quand j'étais jeune ou
ce qu'on appelle le cassoulet créole
c'est à dire haricots rouges et
répéter c'est un peu nous sommes
dangereux pour le chauffage ce
gestionnaire du réseau électrique rte
qui préconise une réduction de la
consommation aujourd'hui l'opérateur qui
demande aux entreprises aux
collectivités de modérer leur
consommation entre 7h et 10h il est
également préférable de descendre la
température à 16 degrés lorsque l'on
quitte son logement est recommandé aussi
de préville et le mode eco vous savez
c'est ce qu'ils seront par exemple sur
vos appareils tels que le lave linge le
sèche linge ou encore le lave vaisselle
il n'est pas recommandé de couper la
télé avoue rester à m
il ne peut donc quasiment jamais mais il
suffit d'en parler pour que soudain
c'est incroyable pluie assez incroyable
tu vois ça fait deux ans qu'il pleut pas
hugo est venu où elle là il a plus tard
c'est moi ou c'est toi c'est toi tu y
croies sétoise c'est quand même dingue
au
[Applaudissements]
donc vous le savez un nouveau ton dans
battant en cinq jours toujours alors
votez pour qui dit le alors je vais vous
le dire j'avais je suis sûr maintenant
de moi je vais voter pour
doit se quitter on doit se quitter plus
tôt parce que comme ça vous aurez
l'immense plaisir de voir les clips
électoraux juste après cette émission
regardez regardez c'est pas beau ça à
réconcilier la mine une aide
individuelle et un ratio net c'est ce
que je fais modestement dans tes pump et
cyril hanouna mais ça c'est bien
et
intrants et
tout ça pourquoi tout ça pour keable
pour celui qui tenait son seul et unique
meeting de campagne emmanuel macron
attention pas le président mais le
candidat
qui était heureux
sur ce n'est pas qu'il a chanté la
marseillaise c'est qu'il a il a vécu la
marseillaise ils étaient en transe il a
littéralement pris la bastille
[Musique]
là
là quand les yeux flanche
oui c'est génial mais vous rendez compte
mais sait on l'écrit rsa dans un
scénario personne ne nous croire et
c'est quand même fantastique